robots are gearing up to serve
so you pay in advance you scan a qr code
and the ice cream switch is flipped oh
it's with smiley eyes
apparently it's only serving up vanilla
soft serve but uh apparently there are a
variety of topping
options it's important to have the
variety of topping options a cute little
robot really cute
i remember once this has been a while
back as heather wasn't here yet we
talked about flavors of ice cream that
we liked yes and i recall that john
langler picked vanilla i did
vanilla what is wrong with vanilla
vanilla is fine it's the base layer it's
the plain old no
vanilla it's like it's like it's like at
the beginning it's a primer if that is
your favorite then that means that
that's all you like well
yeah you can't have any added flavors i
will not stand for this aggression i
will not stand for this vanilla
aggression sprinkles nothing no you're
vanilla man
no tutti frutti for you cut off no
chocolate sauce nothing
my words have been taken out of context
slightly
slightly
well you could add a little chocolate
sauce right heather
i don't know why i remember that but
that just popped into my head when you
see me you just think vanilla
[Laughter]
it's not true all right we are